What job that does not exist today do you think will be one of the world's "top 10" jobs in 10 years?
I think, and I'm speaking about my industry
so the company I work for
is a company that is engaged in supporting our clients
in defining this work environment.
And what we are seeing already today
but will increase definitely in the future
is the involvement of people
that have skills that are not directly related
to products themselves,
but people who understand mainly other,
let's say, sciences,
so people who can,
who are able to equate together concepts
that go from anthropology
to sociology
to psychology.
If you think about the impact
that the work environment can give to the people
working in that environment,
it's really important to have the ability
to understand what people are expecting
from a work environment
and translate that into an effective formula
that, in the end, could bring effective results.
So, something we are seeing today
but will definitely develop tomorrow
is really the ability to understand
different cultures.
So, we study different cultures.
We had just, we just conducted a study
to see how people behave in places
like Beijing
or Monterey
or Los Angeles
and to understand also
how the culture code, as we call it,
impacts those work environments.
So, I think the more the world is globalizing,
the more we see emerging economies becoming relevant,
the more, I think, these profiles
that are not necessarily only driven
by technical knowledge
will be profiles that will have a certain impact
and importance in our industry.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.